speaking of conspiracy theories i want
to talk now about fox host maria
bartiromo
back in january a republican gave maria
the idea that there's going to be a
mid-term covet variant the idea being
that this is a contrived imaginary
variant meant specifically
for democrats i guess
to
justify
new or returning mandates related to the
pandemic and i guess somehow help them
win in november although i'll be honest
i don't even know how a midterm variant
would help democrats in the sense that
if all of a sudden you need lots of new
restrictions
and it's democrats that are in power
wouldn't voters say oh look democrats
have failed us because we've got to do
restrictions again it doesn't even make
any sense to me but maria bartoromo
likes it so here's where she first got
the idea this was during an interview in
january with
us senate candidate the current missouri
attorney general eric schmidt he seemed
to have kind of given her the idea of a
midterm variant and she liked it take a
look back with the ag of missouri eric
schmidt and uh a.g you also questioned
the timing of the mandates and why he
circumvented congress and put it all on
osha which doesn't have such legislative
authority
no and i think that's exactly right you
think back here
joe biden had taken this off the table
he had said many times that he wasn't
going to have a vaccine mandate
afghanistan happened which is perhaps
the worst foreign policy disaster in
generations a betrayal of the american
soldier billions of dollars of equipment
left behind
a total disaster and then immediately
after that to change the narrative he
announces these vaccine mandates which
are clearly unconstitutional unlawful
and you know why the supreme court
agreed with us in court last week but i
think it was a distraction and a cynical
one at that and the american people
deserve better but look this has never
been about the policy this is about
power and control and they're going to
continue to do this you watch maria the
things that he can't get done
legislatively is going to continue to
move forward administratively whether
it's on quote-unquote climate change
we've got an existential threat we've
got uh you know all we're at a tipping
point he's going to charge the deputy
under secretary of the epa who's not
accountable to anybody to do these
things and we're going to push back if
he can't get federal you know he can't
federalize the elections there'll be a
midterm variant watch that's coming
where he empowers administrative
agencies but the good news here is the
states are going to continue to fight
back to protect individual rights and
help save this country
yeah i think you're right about that
midterm election variant it's it's a
great point
so there was maria bartiromo first
getting that idea
and now she's repeating this constantly
i'm not gonna play all five or six
examples of it for you but here is one
from uh her show two days ago this was
from her um fox business mornings with
maria program here she is now she's
taken this midterm variant thing hook
line and sinker we don't know the extent
of the investigation yet maria and i
think the reason for doing this the
reason this guy has stepped in and put
up millions of dollars to take care of
hunter biden bailing him out once again
is that it's pretty embarrassing for the
president of the united states to have
his son go to jail i mean the bottom
line they do probably have a cause uh
for indicting hunter biden and putting
him on trial and nobody
on the left wants to see that happen but
i have to say this whole thing i i mean
i think when republicans take over
control of congress which i hope and
expect to happen in november i think
there's going to be a lot of
investigation of really what has gone on
here where does all this money come from
if hunter biden's been making so much
money on ukrainian and chinese and
russian deals how in the world did he
not pay his taxes why did that happen
why was he lying to the irs because
that's basically what you're talking
about uh i think it's astonishing that
all this has gone on and the liberal
media continues to be completely
uninterested in the story
yeah well you said when the republicans
take over how about if the republicans
take over because the washington post is
reporting more covet
on the horizon in the fall as i've been
predicting the midterms variant
okay the midterms vary all right so
let's break this down in in pieces
first and foremost have democrats
created any variant of course not no
that's absurd are there more and more
coveted cases yes in fact covet cases
are spiking dramatically i'm not
necessarily saying anything in
particular should be done i'm not giving
you my medical opinion because i'm not a
doctor what i'm telling you is covid
cases are increasing dramatically the us
was down up to about 28 000 official
cases a day in late march
the us is now all the way back up to 70
000 cases a day and with so many people
not testing at all
or testing at home and not reporting
that they're sick
the real number of infections could be 2
or even three times as high we might
already be back up to somewhere between
150 000 and 200 000 cases a day am i
saying that we should do anything
differently no i'm not saying anything
one way or the other that's for medical
experts to decide but cases are spiking
like crazy that's number one number two
maria bartoromo seems to be suggesting
that it is the democrats that come up
with strategically timed contrived uh
stories or issues
meant to benefit them in elections but
the truth is that it's republicans who
have a very long history of doing that
ebola in 2014 i remember reporting on it
eight years ago
leading up to the midterm elections of
2014 rep i remember covering rand paul i
remember i remember i see myself sitting
in the old studio covering these stories
republicans were going crazy about the
ebola pandemic which was essentially
uh contained in west africa i think that
there were between two and four
cases that got to the u.s
one of which died and they didn't even
catch it in the us i don't remember the
details but we're talking about numbers
you can count on one hand
and i told everybody
this issue disappears the day after the
midterms
and we never heard about it again after
the midterms that was a contrived issue
by republicans another example the
migrant caravans every time we start
getting close to an election fox news
migrant caravan is departing in
nicaragua heading all the way up they're
expected at the u.s mexico border six
weeks eight weeks from now what
democrats aren't doing anything about it
the migrant caravan story is a contrived
issue
with the timing meant to help
republicans in
elections midterm elections and general
elections voter fraud i mean again
that was timed starting six months
before the 2020 election to have a very
particular effect which i won't even go
into now because you all know about it
already
it is the republicans who do the
carefully and deliberately timed fake
issues
a midterm variant what we have is
another coveted spike
and why we have it and what should be
done are not the topics for this segment
but the idea that democrats have uh uh
created that in any way is completely
absurd and the really sad thing is i've
said it before
maria bartoromo used to be a good
financial reporter 20 years ago when i
first got into following the stock
market i'd watch her on cnbc in the
morning before school she really was
doing good financial reporting she's
become a conspiracy nut trump brown
noser and it's a really a shame it
really is
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night improves sleep
in many ways
our sponsor chilly sleep creates systems
that cool down your bed promoting deeper
higher quality sleep it also just feels
great i use it at home i'd recommend it
to anyone and i've recommended it to
some friends who now use it as well
chili sleeps product the uhler the cube
and the doc pro
they're all water-based temperature
controlled pads that fit onto your
existing mattress you can keep your bed
as low as 55 degrees as hot as 115
degrees i like 60 their new doc pro
sleep system has double the cooling
power of other models five times the
cooling contact whisper quiet you can
control it with your phone it's awesome
with chilly sleep there's no more
feeling hot at night no more sweating
cooling your bed down like this is
amazing you really have to try it for
yourself when you go to chilisleep.com
pacman you'll get 30 off of the uhler
and cube sleep systems and 10 off the
new doc pro this offer is only for my
audience the link is down below